The Joe Rogan experience.
When you have these moments where things don't go well, or you have a fall,
or when you had your concussion, when you got really banged up,
overcoming those things, what is that like?
Cause I would imagine that it's such a scary thing to do. Well, maybe for me,
I know as much for you, but watching pictures of you, my hands, sweat,
not like legitimately,
like Alex Honnold freaks me out every time I see videos of him.
Cause he's got no nothing saving him. My hands start sweating.
No, I think all our hands, sweat when we watch him. But, um,
yeah. So for me, it's I think, for example, when I,
when I hit my head this time, the time I got the scar, um,
I was on one of my day had gone so perfectly. Like I was climbing super well,
everything was great. I, there it is. Um, yeah, that was the rock bottom moment.
So I was climbing and I was in the sun. I slipped off.
I felt like I was just going to have a really normal fall, super safe,
like nothing bad was going to happen.
And then I hit my head and I instantly like just felt the blood pouring down my
face and it was super dramatic and it was super scary.
And I lowered down and Adrian sort of assessed me for concussion
symptoms and tried to figure out if there was anything super serious.
And it turns out that there wasn't really. Um, and so it,
it came time to decide like, Oh, should I keep going? Or should I,
should I give up like what, you know what, what's the best course of action now.
And honestly, in my head, I was like, part of me was like,
I don't want to keep climbing.
Like I'm emotionally kind of destroyed and, and drained.
And I don't think I can.
No, it happened like what, what was the sequence of events.
I was,
so I was climbing this pitch and it's a pitch that I've never fallen on before.
Um, and the next pitch is the hard one,
which is where I think I went wrong because I was sort of thinking ahead,
like I wasn't focusing on what was happening in front of me.
I was thinking about the, the next pitch. And I was like,
I need to get this one out of the way so that I can focus on the hard one.
And therefore I was climbing the sun when it's too hot.
Like the friction's not as good. It's more slippery, all those things. Um,
and I was rushing it. I didn't rest enough. Friction.
Is not as good when it's hot. Yeah.
You want it to be cold because your skin sweats and like the
rubber on your shoes isn't as sticky.
Like it's just the heat that heat radiates off the rock.
It just gets more slippery. Like imagine like a,
a granite face just like baking in the sun.
Like everything's more slippery and you're, you're all sweaty.
And so it's just not ideal. Um, and I could have waited, but I didn't.
So I climb, I was climbing and I was like, kind of traversing.
And so I was trying to do this move and I rushed it and I slipped and I
fell, but I had like a piece of gear down into my right.
And I just didn't,
I just didn't anticipate like the physics of how I was going to fall.
And I kind of fell sideways and I couldn't get my feet out in front of me in
time. And we watched the footage later. It was just like,
it was kind of like my head just like bounces off the wall, like a,
like a basketball. Um,
and I must have just hit like a crystal or something with my forehead,
like some sort of something sticking out of the rock. Um,
and there was just blood everywhere, like head wounds. They just, you know,
they bleed, they bleed a lot.
And so there was a lot of blood and lower down and it was super bummed.
It was just like, my confidence was sort of shattered. Like I could,
I just kept thinking back to last year, I was like, Oh no,
my attempts over everything was going so well. Like the socks.
And I was letting myself go to that place of doubt and that place of like,
it's over.
And last year when you hit your head, you hit your head much harder.
Last year I fell on the first pitch of the route. Um, so close to the ground.
Uh, and, but I felt like 50 feet and I hit a ledge and didn't the rope. Like,
didn't catch me. I hit the ledge because I was, uh, again,
rushing and not placing enough protection and.
Fell 50 feet without being caught.
Hit a leg. Oh God. Yeah. It was a really, it was pretty gnarly. I, it,
I don't remember. Cause I got knocked out. Yeah. Um,
but I had this crazy rope burn on my neck and um,
yeah, it was, it was pretty, I had, yeah, we,
I had to get rescued like full on ambulance to the hospital.
Like spinal injury worries, all that.
It was pretty serious. It was definitely the worst accident I've ever had. Um,
and it was, I walked out of the hospital that day, which is incredible.
Like that just doesn't happen very often. There's me.
Dressed up like a burrito and what,
so this is when they were carrying you to the hospital.
Yeah. That's a rope burn. I also don't know how that happened. Oh,
wow. Yeah.
Wow. And there's no footage of this, right? You didn't,
you didn't review footage of it.
Well, it was dark when I started climbing.
So actually his footage of Alex Honnold was belaying me. Um,
there's footage of him belaying me.
What is blaming blaming is the person who holds your rope at the bottom.
So he was like, essentially holding my rope,
but it's a little bit nuanced because the way we were climbing,
we were doing something called Simon climbing. Um, we were,
so we were essentially, I was tied on the top of the rope.
He was tied onto the bottom of the rope and we were climbing together up the
walls simultaneously in order to save time. And it's actually,
it is a more dangerous form of climbing than just like
one person climbing while the other person belays them. And then they,
and then I would stop and bring him up and then we'd go on from there.
Like instead we were climbing together. Whoa.
That makes me nervous. Just thinking about it. So if someone falls,
you're kind of connected to them.
Yeah. We were always connected to somebody when you fall. Um,
but if he had fallen, it would, it's,
it's kind of a complicated form of climbing that not many people do. Um,
it's definitely like a, an advanced strategy.
Um, but so was someone filming? Yeah. I have a,
I have a filmer. Who's making like a, a movie about me.
Um,
and he was filming cause he was there filming that attempt and he was filming
Alex as Alex was like sitting on the ground, getting ready.
And have you reviewed the footage? Yeah. What was it like watching yourself?
It's pretty, it's pretty like it's, it's hard. It was hard.
I didn't watch it for the first few months. I was like, I don't know.
How long does it take to fall 50 feet? It would imagine that's a few seconds.
I dunno. What's the fall.
Isn't it like not nine point. Yeah. 9.8 meters per second.
So it's a couple of seconds.
Um, at least it felt that way.
Oh God.
So that was, that was something like a mental hurdle to get over for this year.
And then this year, something similar happens only I was way higher on the wall,
but I was really close to succeeding this time.
And I had this part of me was like, well, I just want to give up, like,
I don't want to do this anymore. I want to be done. Like,
I'm tired of this project. I'm over it.
When you got over the first injury that the, the really bad one from last year,
what was the process of recovery?
Like how long did it take before you felt comfortable enough to climb again?
You know, I was super lucky. I think I definitely got away with one.
It was one of those things where I got away with one,
like I walked out of the hospital. I was, um, back climbing.
I took, I think I took a month off, but I went to, like,
I went to Ecuador and climb to a volcano with my dad and like went skiing and
just did a bunch of things. Like how long is fine.
We went to Ecuador like four days later.
Yeah. Kind of crazy father do you have?
He's awesome.
My dad loves all sports and activities and he's like super passionate about
everything.
And this was his dream was to like go climb this volcano in Ecuador and we'd
been planning it for months.
And I actually felt that was one of the reasons I felt so bad that I got hurt.
It was like, I was like, Oh no, I'm supposed to go on this trip with my dad.
And like we had, you know, we had this whole plan. He's been training.
He trained like for months he's 65 years old. Like, Hey,
you know, it was one of those things.
So we went and we climbed the mountain and like,
thankfully I was able to do that with her.
And it was really cool,
but kind of like physical damage.
Did you suffer in terms of like how long did it take for you to recover?
I, I honestly, I would say I felt pretty normal within a month. Yeah.
A little back pain, but concussion cushion. Yeah.
The concussion symptoms were a little gnarly for a little while.
But four days later you're climbing a volcano. Well, we're headed there. Yeah.
How long after that before you were actually I.
Maybe like three weeks.
So while you were suffering from some,
at least concussion symptoms, you were climbing.
Yeah. Not recommended. We went to the doctor and she was like,
you can't go to Ecuador. You shouldn't do that. And I was like, yeah,
that's nice.
When, when you watch the footage of the fall and you, you know,
when you see yourself hit the wall and just the impact and
what happened to you does that obviously didn't deter you
from doing anything, but has it changed the way you approach climbing?
Yes and no. I,
I think the reason that it was a little bit easier for me to overcome that
hurdle was because I was, it was really obvious what had gone wrong.
And it was really obvious that the,
what had gone wrong wrong was within my control.
Like I simply had not placed enough protection for the difficulty of the
route. Um, it was an easy, easy climbing for me,
but it was really dark. It was cold. It was slippery. And I was like,
I was just going too fast and not placing enough gear.
Episodes of the Joe Rogan experience are now free on Spotify. That's right.
They're free from September 1st to December 1st,
they're going to be available everywhere.
But after December 1st they will only be available on Spotify,
but they will be free. That includes the video. The video will also be there.
It'll also be free. That's all we're asking. Go download Spotify much.
Buh-bye.
Okay.